[Music]
speaking of adonis paul
i heard you saw this but i feel like we
have to share this with everybody
you know i feel like we have to share
this with everybody
uh this
is how do we exp how do i explain this
um
frozen explain what this is it's a
parody
yes it's a parody of course but it's uh
it's an interesting parody that uh might
induce a certain emotion
okay okay so this is why
um i'm for bullying theater kids
um this one is uh this is not the title
of the video but the donnis paul put it
up first
it's titled literally the worst thing
ever filmed oh no
oh no since we're talking about no oh no
we're talking about kovitch
we're talking about covetousness we're
talking about covid what we're gonna do
is yes
since we're talking about covert what
we're gonna do is we're gonna listen to
this
little ditty okay please welcome the
president of the united states
joe r biden
come on folks let's get back on the town
with all those jabs i'm gonna work this
out
and bring our cases down
with all those jabs i'm trying to pass
my reform bill
this is why the theater kids are like
the only group i never felt bad about
like even in my adult life being mean to
no me either [ __ ] those kids with joe
manchin
here don't think i ever will and still
on top of this we're in a health crisis
with all those
[Music]
jabs
once this is not my fault because i
didn't bring this
somebody likes to play dress-up hmm
gensake here come on down and get a shot
let's be fair that's that we know it's
not gen soccer
it's not working oh
easy but we know this isn't gen soggy
because this person's
clearly way hotter than jets oh come on
mike that's really mean
of all those jabs but shooting shots is
not our only thing to do
oh no it's not just jabs i feel
like this feels like um this feels like
um
like crowder had heterosexual sex one
time and knocked somebody up years ago
and this is like his long-lost son this
feels like crowder's long-lost son
republicans are not a fan of our
multi-trillion dollar budget plan
but whilst our team reviewed we're
trying to distribute
and do those
jobs
you know i i went from like hoping that
hoping that i'm wrong and that the uh
that nothing bad does come of this covet
vaccine
to now comfortably settled in with
the people that have gotten it versus
the people that haven't i'm okay with
there being
just far-reaching complications down the
road
there's just at this point if you're
getting it now at this point
yeah but this guy's got to crush a lot
of puss you got to think
what if he's one of them what if he's
one of those low-key guys that's like
legit straight
oh yeah but pretends to be gay every
theater like milo
like milo exactly he pretended to be
gay's whole life yeah then switched
but uh we had a kid like that in high
school we all thought he was gay
and he ended up it ended up coming out
like years later they were like yeah
everybody was [ __ ] that kid like for
real and it was like damn like
homie had it in i mean it was a weird it
was a weird way to go about it because
he
the rest of his life was hell in school
but but he did get [ __ ]
[Music]
what an unfortunate existence
you know jj said something this morning
he goes you should have to apply for a
permit before you get a green screen
he's right you have to pay like two
thousand dollars a year to the federal
government or something
you shouldn't just give green screens
out this kid is uh
i mean i hate to say this i know this
sounds mean if this was my kid i would
hate him
you know like i'm sorry it's true though
if this was your son i'm not saying
you'd hate him but would you
like you would be bummed out every time
he was around
right of course like it's like hey like
you're like trying to be normal
hi dad and you're like hey listen we got
tickets we're going to go see the pro
bowl this year we like to go usually
we're going to we're going to go to pro
bowl and he's the one like doing like da
da
in the parking lot you're like just
twirling around like a [ __ ] male
cheerleader and you're like god damn it
man like
like i it's okay that's a natural
feeling if you have a son
although honestly if you have a son and
he grows up like this
you there were some parts in that choose
your own adventure book that you went
wildly wrong too let's be fair they
don't come out
this much like this unless pop [ __ ] up
at some point
well you know it's funny he was actually
the starting quarterback of the varsity
team until he got the uh
vaccine oh is this what happened yeah oh
no
yeah oh no is this like this is like a
young johnny football
[Music]
to do that
oh there's no more hiding
because the best part is you know this
took him like a week to make and he had
like in between takes he worked so hard
on this but in between takes you had to
leave and go to his job at panera bread
yeah you're right yeah or chipotle yes
okay every word i could use to describe
this would get us
i know you know okay this is very funny
because what did i what did i say today
frozen on day wave when adonis played
this
i said there's so many things i want to
say
but i can't say them on youtube the list
of words you're not allowed to use as
descriptive adjectives anymore is
unfortunate